gang the middle class famous tour is
about to be in full effect come out and
see us it's a great way to introduce
some new people to the show so grab the
homies grab the ladies the birds the
bozos everybody and come see us yeah
guys we're going to be in hartford
albany syracuse atlanta tampa orlando
pittsburgh buffalo we ain't done yet
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago then over there to roseman and
that's just the first leg of the tour
gonna be coming so get the techies we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
ru garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they grow up to be classy or
just a big old piece of trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antoni's basement she's upstairs she's
all excited she loves the winner yeah
big fan of the winner or she calls it
slip and fall season
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of are you
garbage according to the gossip rags he
left quite the tip at minetta tavern
this weekend
and there was whisk away to dance the
night away with jeff bezos and kim
kardashian over there at oak one the
kid's a [ __ ] player look out give it
up for kj kevin james ryan hey what's up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
cook and baby and then obviously the
greatest website of all time uh
patreon.com are you garbage you can sign
up you get bonus episodes ayg a whole
different podcast you might not even
know about called hard feelings yeah me
and the big man and t-bone little behind
the curtains who left the hairs down
that's like a real hr type thing it's
the airing of grievances uh and
obviously live streams every month as
well for our top tier patrons check it
out of course another nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire and
he does the weather on the twos give it
up for t-bone mcmuffin it's toby
mcbuttons everybody what up t-bone i'm
excited to have the sensei of garbage
back in yes sir
because gang we got a little company in
the building he's family at this point
back he's our uh he's our rich cousin
from the coast he lives out there in
hollywood
do you know regis philbin
i know you took a plane here but you
have i took the bus across country i
have taken the bus uh quite a distance
in my time the mega bus as they call it
they i mean i was having megabus
flashbacks coming here because i've been
at that 34th street stop where they just
drop you like here's the stop there's no
station they just dropped you like 30.
it's like 34th street like 18th avenue
there's no sign it's a pole mm-hmm it's
a pole that's like philadelphia yeah and
you line up there you're like is this
the one that feels like this is going to
chicago you're like what yeah oh my god
yeah no and going to like buffalo it's
nine hours on the mega bus through
syracuse through all the fun towns like
binghamton you know it's real trashy is
when you're on the bus and you stop at a
rest stop at with the whole bus oh
that's and you act like you're a family
you're like oh you're doing wendy's i
was going to do roy rogers it's so
[ __ ] up hang on there's still two more
in the bathroom give him a couple of
minutes i told sally we wait for him
that really is where you bond with your
fellow bus mates because you're like oh
how was the line over at uh you know
dunkin donuts and they tell you they're
like i didn't even go there i was like i
just took a
[ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen the host of the
josh potter show mr josh potter oh thank
you thank you thank you
there's also two you really put a lot of
trust in the guy next to you because
you're like don't let this [ __ ] bus
leave without me pal
make sure make sure i'm [ __ ] back
trying to sneak in 80s real quick have
you had the uh
have you had the bus driver that's like
a real
bus nazi where he's like and if you're
not back oh yeah in 15 this bus is gone
oh yeah laying down laying down the
rules for what happens if you miss it
you're [ __ ] you gotta wait till the
you know wait six hours till the next
day the next day probably yeah [ __ ] buy
some cologne in a watch or whatever
that was the question i wanted to ask i
wanted to ask you what is the what's the
longest bus stop you ever touched uh
nine hours i mean that's like that's
like a paul simon song that was
everything every time i came to new york
from buffalo it was either i upgraded at
some point to the train i discovered the
train i discovered the
he didn't mean train bought a ticket he
was jumping on the back i thought you've
been upgraded of the mega bus
shotgun i've done that pay for the extra
preferred seating what do you what's
preferred seating you get to choose your
seat uh i think you get to board first
choose your seat it's like an extra 18
cents it's like why don't you do it how
many miles you get on that car there was
a time i went on to the mega bus
only there was it was full and like
people like were hogging they were
putting like their luggage on seats and
i was like where's people move in yeah
and i was like where should i ask the
bus driver like there's nowhere to sit
and she was like
uh and then she went got up and took her
luggage out of the seat behind her and
put it like in the rack
and go sit there and i go you were you
were hogging a seat
[ __ ]
luggage
it's [ __ ] up
she made you first mate it was the best
seat too yeah it was like not amongst
the
near
trashiest one is the one on the second
floor looking out i like that oh you sit
there you're trying to feel like you're
on the enterprise dude [ __ ] cooking i
feel like i'm gonna get ejected through
it it's like you're on the bridge of the
cornelia dude
[ __ ] you're like the titanic uh captain
where he's just staring out you have a
cup of tea
one of the last times i took it i was
going to philly for a show from new york
uh megabus i was a megabus man and uh
the cops were on the cops came on the
bus before he even left because the same
thing a woman didn't want to move her
luggage to let another woman sit there
and then it was really just to prove a
point they were like miss you can sit
over here she's like i want to [ __ ]
sit there and they're like the guy's
like i'm just going to call the cops to
like call him i'm like well if i'm not
making this show like [ __ ] 45 minutes
doesn't happen in the amex lounge at
[ __ ] laguardia no it does not that's
[ __ ] but i've uh when i when i found
amtrak
amtrak that's that's [ __ ] expensive
real expensive is it
yeah amtrak were you riding on the roof
what do you mean
that was like 30 dollars
really
well
well there's one from philly to from new
york to philly that's like it's like a
fight it's like it's like a ticket to
miami dude it's like 180 bucks no [ __ ]
yeah well i guess
you're coming in three minutes it's like
super quick and it's like first class or
whatever like business well yeah if you
get business well that's what i i'm
learning now i uh i take the amtrak from
la to san diego quite a bit which is
beautiful by the way you go down you see
the ocean it's the best view even the
amtrak here is pretty nice or yeah it's
uh you know go through the woods and
[ __ ] but when you get business class you
get that business class lounge yes which
is not like the united lounge or the
delta lounge it's just a coffee machine
it's just another set of seats and you
don't have to sit with hobos and [ __ ]
you know what i mean so you just get to
get like oh people with pants cool yeah
it's just less dicks yeah nobody [ __ ]
themselves in here but i never found it
that expensive but maybe like i said
coming from philly to new york has got
to be an amtrak that is high demand yeah
it's like a hub to hub type thing right
you take the train a lot out there yeah
to go to san diego especially
and i took it a lot out here too i was
taking it from buffalo to dc to
uh when you were working the road you
were stationed out of buffalo yeah but
and i didn't want it
there's even a train that does that
[ __ ] you go all the way around
you gotta stop in chile you gotta go all
the way to new york and then come
through new york and go
it's not a great route but if you can't
afford panama canals
could be a lot of traffic i feel like
you're riding freight train suicide i
know
he's got a stick with a bindle on it
he's got his merch his josh potter merch
in there
i sell i also sell people guitar
[Laughter]
i bet you could start a fire in a barrel
really really good
get that thing
i just use my glasses
the sun hits them just right
the hobos thought he was a wizard
have you ever jumped a train in your
youth uh i have like not for very far
because like it started getting going
and i was like oh god and then i had to
try and get off i gotta be over dinner
yeah
i got scared i'm like i don't know where
this is going
that's crazy
just hopping random drinks i was goofing
off after school i ended up in indiana
we did it yeah we didn't even think
about the like ramifications it was
going somewhere yeah i literally love
the thought i'm gonna get on that thing
and then you're on there where is this
going yeah we're like i gotta get off
holy [ __ ] i didn't think this through
yeah how long are you supposed to ride
it when you jump on it like that i don't
know i've never done so the heat blows
over i don't know
especially you're supposed to go out
west we also start goal mining
you're changing your life
yeah you're like seven rolling the dice
with like 400 souls yeah yeah
that's crazy
it's like the edmond fitzgerald if
you're talking in souls that's bad news
because you don't think there's anybody
on the train because you just think
there's like cows or hay or whatever
they're like i've never looked at a
train and thought there was cows or hate
i don't know what they have on there
probably all zebras what do you think's
on there i don't know boxes
crates of uh i thought crates of animals
you know i don't know like uh that's not
noah's ark it's like a cartoon
there's like a gorilla in
there potter thinks everyone's the
circus train yeah
a lot of circus is in town this week huh
that's the elephant car
giraffe's heads are sticking out
it's usually oil and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] oil cargo mm-hmm
they've been hand-picking over there in
uh
in l.a in the train oh my god i uh i
sent my mom a christmas present in
january uh
that because it was that way top-notch
sunday yeah
i told her i'm like it's coming late and
it wasn't if you don't mind me asking
did you blame the supply chain on it
this is oh dude this is why jane's been
getting [ __ ]
bad do bad mouth in my apartment
hardcore i uh
my gift for my mother was a podcast
sponsor uh so i think that's like is
that trash to give my mom like a free
podcast sponsor what was it a helicopter
or a frame
an or a frame oh i thought you were
going to shout her out on the on the pod
it was like
she
this podcast is brought to you by my mom
it's patricia potter one of my sponsors
is this company aura frames it's like a
digital picture frame thing where you
can upload pictures into it and they
sent me like they also might sponsor us
well they sent me five and they sent you
five i kept i got like fi all of a
sudden i'm like i have two and so i sent
one to my aunt my mom my
and uh looking like a big shot i guess
but i don't want them all to know that i
got them for free i want them to think i
purchased these you know so have a fake
receipt but i don't even know they won't
even talk to it that's the great thing
like
the aunt that i sent it to doesn't
really talk to my mom my mom won't talk
to my
my dad's wife so they don't know that
they all got these or affirmations
that's pretty good though i'll give you
that it's not a bad little setup it's a
nice little scam yeah what heck i'm not
going the sisters don't talk
they're not sisters they're uh like
cross sister and what is it
so i've kept it all pretty
they all think they're got a special
aura cleaned up all your loose ends
i made sure the aura frame doesn't point
i had to kill an amazon driver but other
than that i think i'm in the clear
[ __ ] yeah if not i hop to train to
the east coast but i did i sent it uh
it was like two weeks after christmas i
felt i told my mom i'm like you're
getting it late because
i don't i wasn't around
during christmas time but she didn't
care and then i saw the
that footage of the trains in la where
like the packages are all
demolished yeah and i knew my mom had
seen this footage and she is already
she was calling my sister being like i'm
not going to be home when the package is
supposed to come can you go wait at the
house
i'm like my sister goes what are you
sending her that i got to go wait at the
house yeah it's a free frame that i got
yeah i told her i'm like it's not a big
deal i go i got another one if it gets
lost
i'll resend it i got a whole roof yeah
it's still not there yet no it arrived
but in but my sister was like i'm not go
so i don't have to go sit at the house
and wait for this i go no don't even if
someone steals it off her porch or if it
never gets there i'll send another one
it's fine that is the one thing man you
get mad about that [ __ ] but they do just
send you another one i just had a
[ __ ] vacuum stolen from her
vacuum off the porch out of our i mean a
port i don't have a porch but uh in the
lobby
i forget where we are
i even have a porsche it's right next to
my rocking chair you believe that
they took the wind chimes and all
you got to put a screen up out there any
time you take a riffraff out i have an
apartment it's in like a complex but
it's more like melrose place sure it's
like we have we have a small like
stoop for sure for sure so there's no
like hallway or whatever but i get that
the hallway
the culprits are in your building well
that's what i was saying
i well that's like that so that's what
we were like uh yeah i agree with that
100 by the way that they're in the
building
they were like we can pull the tapes
because you know uh cause we were gone
for a night or something we were in
philly i think or we're down the shore
pull the tapes well they were like i've
never pulled the tape so far i would
love to do that
but then i didn't want to because i'm
like i don't want to find out it's
someone in the building and then i have
to hate them for like 150 bucks
that's crazy that's going to ruin the
rest of i'm going to think about that
all right dude look at
that you're not sweating cash right now
well no they're replacing it no that's
my point though but like
i wouldn't for 150 yeah i would have
been like what if they take more [ __ ]
from you yeah dude you gotta you got
listen no that's a cancer in the
building you gotta find them you gotta
publicly embarrass them then you gotta
toss them out on there you don't even
have to do anything just know who it is
and then you secretly when you see the
other neighbors you go
you know 404 over there
real sticky fingers keep an eye yeah
watch your packaging clean this carpet
in the building yeah uh yeah i just
didn't want to [ __ ] i i just don't i
don't need that in my life as i'm also
wildly insane so it would be v you know
what i mean it would just start doing
[ __ ] that you don't even really want to
do you know like you're doing things to
[ __ ] with yes exactly and i'm like i'd
be like leaving packages out to like see
if i can catch them again type thing you
know what i mean you're leaving packages
that are like anthrax
you're saying booby traps of bleach and
ammonia
yeah it's like ted kaczynski's there's
just nails and stuff inside that's what
it's going to turn to yeah
send them a light yeah
start leaving little notes
ah that's dude you're cr dude you that
that's an irresponsible citizen right
there to be honest with you
think about the thousands of dollars
because you're not just [ __ ]
listen you get your hands on a vacuum
cleaner then you got a taste for it
they're not walking away from that life
these people that steal the packages
such a [ __ ] scumbag move it's a
scumbag move and
they don't know what's in these [ __ ]
that's what i don't get you know how
many but you know how many just like
horribly cheap pieces of [ __ ] things
i've ordered and then like what they're
doing somebody makes out like a three
dollar t-shirt oh cool you stole a yeah
a hoodie congratulations you know what i
mean like they must sometimes get like
that might be the rush like yeah you end
up with like an electronic or something
yeah that's probably the
cleaner oh look at this guy [ __ ]
but they're getting they're getting
smarter because we had a couple empty
boxes downstairs
all right my girl's like what the [ __ ]
is this she's like it was a cat bowl and
then like two days later she looked over
in the other packages and they had
zipped it and [ __ ] just put it when
they saw it was a it was a cat oh so
they repackage it again
no they just threw the package that was
inside the amazon box to the
they look through it now yeah so i guess
so they don't look shifty walking out
with an amazon box they give it a quick
zip girl it takes us do you use your
keys yeah yeah that tape's [ __ ]
anymore yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go
bezos [ __ ] tighten up security a
little bit i don't know how packages
live here because it's all wet and rainy
and snowy all the time like even in l.a
it's it rains like once in a while and
you get a box and it's like the bottom
of it you pick it up and like the bottom
falls out you know yeah
[Laughter]
um
all right let's oh i wanted to mention
too this is a real trashy thing that uh
me and potter went out boozing the other
night and uh what did i do no is it to
me thing
it's all me it's all me
whatever i can see
him that's that's like i got scared
oh god what are you doing yeah i phrased
that wrong uh he took his pants off
running down 13.
um
i did bum two cigarettes from kevin i
thought that's where it was no no by all
means um please looking for i need a sm
i need a bernie buddy when i'm out there
that stink really stays on you when you
go inside in this cold weather yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think about him in like the
market because it's the best smoking
weed or smoking cigs in the cold it's
like i hate it it's too cold i love it
smoking cigs in the heat is disgusting
yeah there's a there's a happy medium
you know what i don't like 72. when you
walk back into that restaurant after
having a [ __ ] heater outside
everybody knows it i think that's
wonderful i think it's cozy let them
know the man's yeah mark in your
territory you think that's cozy
in the winter when you smoke and you
blow out the smoke it's so satisfying
for it to be just this epic plume it's
almost like you're one of these vape
idiots where you got the [ __ ] thing
but then when you're smoking and it's
like 90 and
you're like
and there's nothing and you're like
oh god i just feel hot yeah hotter feels
like you're like next to the [ __ ]
engine of a car you're just sweating
a little sweat on there
it's gross but what happened uh remember
when i was leaving we were we were at uh
were at the uh the stand comedy club and
i was leaving and they had closed and my
cred they had my credit card and i was
like oh [ __ ] but like the staff is like
shut the joint down the staff is like
gone at this point we know the manager i
was talking to the manager and i'm like
he's like oh yeah you know here he goes
so he hands him my card we go we have
another beer at another bar and then i i
leave i go to use my car the next
morning it's not working i'm like oh
that's strange
here this is how big of a piece of trash
i am it was the card i left there eight
months ago
and i canceled and just never went back
and picked up oh so they still have your
currency i still have my current credit
card and gave me mine from eight months
ago
yeah i was just like i can't call them
back and be like hey
you gave me the other one i left there
you know what i mean so i'm not paying
either 10.
i'm having a hard time with cards
after coven it's like i've regressed to
being 23. i have lost my fourth debit
card in three months you can't see them
just like i i literally was the problem
i was in milwaukee last week right
before i came here
and left the debit card and took the
room key
i got to the airport and took the room
key
out
it was
really sad and i go oh my god i gotta go
to new york so i can't i go i have i
thought i'd have the
hotel in milwaukee mail my debit card to
the hotel here so when i got here i
could do that for you well they'll mail
it but
so i thought
to my house they can mail it i don't
know how long it would take you're right
interesting just following them all
around the country oh well
pittsburgh when you get there let's talk
about manscapes
now as we know when you're taking care
of downstairs the lower levels manscape
is your trusted friend subterranean
that's exactly right that's where you go
to when you're digging out the cellar
you know what i mean you're trying to
put down some concrete you need good
equipment that's right but here's the
good news
they're up in the game
they got the old ultra premium
collection that's literally gonna take
care of you from head to toe are you
talking about an all-in-one skin and
hair kit that's exactly what i'm talking
about i'm talking about joining the four
million men that are already involved
love that money so let's rock and roll
yes go to manscape.com for 20 off plus
free shipping with the code garbage yeah
they were nice enough to send it to me
but i was supposed to give half of it to
you you son of a big buddy but i'm
dancing all over the place i wonder why
you smell so good feeling like you got
an extra pep in your stomach you're all
manscaped up you're about to slip off
the chair over there i got you this
guy's high on the premium ultra
collection yes uh they got premium
deodorant uh hydrating body spray body
wash two in one shampoo and conditioner
top to bottom they take care of you so
you get 20 off plus free shipping with
code garbage at manscape.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with code garbage
at manscape.com the power of attraction
is now in a bottle thanks to manscape
there we go do it kippy let's talk about
bespoke post baby box of awesome boxer
awesome winter time i'm thinking hmm
what's inside a bunch of cool stuff
bunch of stuff from small businesses a
bunch of stuff from from from from from
actual people yeah
cool stuff sure that's right baby it
could be outdoor gear could be grooming
stuff could be stuff for the home bar
you want to do yourself a favor this
winter and pick up a box of awesome from
the good people at bespoke post
you sure do turn the canadian there for
a hot second
what are you doing
guys it's cool guys [ __ ] you don't know
you need until you see you go i want
that where are you gonna get your grill
tools you butt heads
so get involved they sent us a whole
bunch of [ __ ] great we got the bag i got
a knife he got a tent we got a we got a
hammock we got everything they release
new boxes every month across a ton of
different categories free to sign up you
can skip a month or cancel at any time
you want to hear the best part about it
what xbox only costs 45 beans but what's
in it 70 worth of gear
uh as the big man said you're supporting
small business with the uh when you when
you enroll in the subscription and
cancel any time the whole nine yards get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up at box of awesome.com and enter
the code garbage at checkout that's box
of awesome.com co garbage for 20 off
your first box do it do it i land though
back in la and i have hundred dollars
charged my card for sheen.com or
sheehan.com which is like some chicks uh
that's like cheap cheap cheap ladies
clothing yeah
clothing yep so
i cancel it now i have to come to new
york and check into a hotel
without a car
and it was like trying to
i don't know it was it was like trying
to make
butter out of nothing
no they wouldn't let me they wouldn't
let me guys mad they went
i wanted what do you mean you don't take
holiday in finally i got them to give me
a credit card authorization form and i
could fill it out but it was like did it
fill out like you had to write your
number down yeah and i had to your
card's still active no i had to get a
see with chase bank when you cancel your
card they put the new one on your phone
so i could use the phone thing you know
the reader pretty good there you go
they won't take that they wanted to do
that they don't have that they need the
physical [ __ ] [ __ ] and i was like
you've got to be kidding me i could walk
up to an atm right now and use this
[ __ ] thing i go to any store but i
can't check into the hotel the room is
paid for but i can't put my incidentals
on this that yeah and now i have to go
to two more hotels without a debit card
i'm like dreading it can you go pick up
a debit card at the place no who do you
no because they don't chase doesn't do
the temporary cards their
their uh
solution is oh we updated on your app
right away i get that that does help you
out of a pinch but i guess if you're
going to [ __ ] yeah if you're in the
metaverse they ain't gonna [ __ ] work
right i'm like yeah exactly i need a
physical card to get around plus my only
fans accounts are expiring and i can't
it's only fan account
all my only fan subscriptions they're
expiring how many the girls are gonna
think i've abandoned them how many
subscriptions we talked about
here
i honestly well here's the thing during
the covid times i they got high
the numbers of subscriptions six
like twelve whoa yeah like i was really
in i thought i was supporting the arts
and so
busy boy but also it got out of hand it
got out of my book
yeah
it got out of my uh
what's the word
over here you know it got out of my i
didn't know until i lost a debit card i
go how many accounts was i
oh we're not talk i don't think you're
getting into like two three dollars an
account right right you're
well i mean i don't know how much they
each are but like it on there oh yeah i
start looking it's like playing a fight
i did an audit though after the last one
i i looked i go on it i go you gotta not
renew this one just stick with the
basics
and you'll be all set it was my highest
utility though at one point
only fans
the write-off at the end of the month
yeah eleven hundred bucks on buttholes
not a butthole provider i don't have any
car payments so i thought why not he
gets audited
i did a self on it because
it was too high keeping yourself in
check i like that
taking taking a bath on titty shots over
here
these guys upside down and only fans i
like you i get sad i got they're going
to think i've abandoned them
i'm not going to be a part of it anymore
but now here i am
i'm right back ladies i'm coming back
just let me get my card five
oh yeah i'm a simp to the max
did they even reach out to you like hey
where you been they're like friends some
of them are convinced to make them
oh really yeah i was like hey you should
get on i don't know if you know about
only fans
but you should probably get on there and
they were in a couple of them like thank
you
this kid 10 coming your way no just
sometimes i get a free this or that you
know
i just i don't need any money for it i
i'm helping the world i'm helping the
economy you know man this gets twisted
[Laughter]
oh man
all right let's get into some [ __ ]
questions here i'm excited uh guys so as
you know when you're doing the patreon
we will uh answer your question on the
air so yeah sorry to do it um we do get
a bunch of people submitting [ __ ] dms
emails the whole nine yards but patreon
gets first dibs but this one came out on
instagram and since we were just talking
about it this is from paul on ig how
garbage is it to check your tab at the
bar to be like hey man can you tell me
what i'm at oh my god
i mean is it garbage is it garbage to
check i feel like that's something that
like financially wise people probably do
like someone who's not even drinking
that much anyways do you know what i
feel like they i feel somewhat i think
you're asking that question because you
got 60 bucks on your card okay you don't
want to go over yeah somebody who's
financially savvy knows okay the beer is
six bucks i've had three plus tax and
tip and they're also not worried if
there is any mischarges on there they
have no problem waiting for the charges
to be reversed over the five to seven
business days which if that was me that
would crumble my account sure yeah yeah
it's a lot of plates spinning you took
it out in two seconds i gotta wait five
days to get it back what the [ __ ] what
kind of bamboozle joint is there oh no i
don't like that trust me but i uh
i think it's more trash like
to do what i would have done probably
and that is run up a crazy tab and then
they go uh your card was declined you go
try this holiday express card
you ever think about starting only fan
yeah
can we supple can we work something out
here
i'll help you get it out there get the
word out
i got a podcast
10 subscriptions oh god yeah i
definitely have done that that's a real
trashy move and also his skin how much
something is
right when you're looking for the
cheapest beer you're looking for bang
for your buck and you're like hey how
much are the budweisers or whatever and
they're like four you're like i don't
ask how much things i mean i'm i don't
drink
uh like opulent beers anyways i drink
like a miller light so it's like i
always know a miller lite
even in the big apple or in la it's
gonna be like eight bucks or something
like sure at the highest end yeah of
course and then you go to buffalo i went
to buffalo and bought five beers
all like blue lights
and
they were they go here's your bill it
was eleven dollars i go oh no i got all
of them yeah and they're like no that is
i know it's great you feel like you go
back in time i couldn't believe it i was
like still i know that's crazy i had a
version of that at trader joe's this
weekend because it was so cheap i was
like what are you [ __ ] an idiot
uh-huh this is what you're saying
yeah guys a [ __ ] bozo he's leaving
money on joe you're leaving money on the
table i thought joe's was expensive but
i guess that now that with the others
around and all these other uh stores
oh you gotta know what erawan is
i know what heroin is
sorry about that blue magic josh
erawan is such an expensive grocery
store that i've actually never stepped
foot into one
really it is spell it e-r-e oh
[Laughter]
like raya that [ __ ] celebrity
h-o-n so it's e-r-e-w-h-r-n arrow on i
guess if i'm saying that homer they
don't have them here nah no i think only
la but it is like beats it looks i mean
people like who go in it say that it is
the best grocery store they've ever been
to but then they say they also have a
bill for like seven hundred dollars
that's crazy that should be one that
should be one of our patreon goals we'll
go to go go to arrow that's what i said
this is like trader joe's that's 12
bucks yeah they look pretty fancy i'll
give them that's what i'm saying and
it's got like that hot bar you know like
where you go up big hot butt we were
just talking about them i love a hot bar
it's like wegmans
but like it's like a fantastic yeah it
looks like a more like uh hipster right
and you're like it's for soccer moms
it's just for influencers you're not
getting chicken wings and [ __ ] or like a
meatball sub or something at arowan you
know where's the stovers yeah you're not
being able to straighten down here we
don't have stovers but we do have and
then it's something you've never heard
of and it cost eighty-five dollars the
whole package is made of gold yeah
exactly salt bay's new brand those leafs
the gold leafs i hate that [ __ ] i
wouldn't i feel like you're biting into
a filling i've never actually tried one
i've never had it scary to me have you
ever eaten gold toby
gold schlager yeah
hey there's gold of that right yeah
right when you were a kid you thought
that was the [ __ ] all the gold dots i
couldn't wait to eat the dots it's real
gold in there man i don't think i ever
had it is it like a rumpleman's what's
it taste like well it's the opposite
it's like the big red you know if like
rumplements is like spearmint gum yeah
it's like uh cinnamon what is that big
red so it's like fireball-esque yeah
it was before farmer i'm like oh so this
is goldschlager everyone's like oh no no
no
what do you do shots
i still do like tequila every now and
then when people ask me to because i am
if i'm anything i am peer pressure
uh susceptible all the time so like if a
person is like a fan wants to do a shot
i'm like i got it what am i going to say
no and make them sad
even though they don't care yeah
the classiest way by the way to handle
the check is to just hand the card
don't ask for the chat oh i never now
that's my favorite thing to do now is
not look at it oh yeah here he goes just
and buying people dinner is my favorite
thing to do nice like yeah it's the best
like you're friends yeah it feels good
like taking care of it is like as a guy
who's had people do that where it just
made me feel emasculated so you're doing
it not to make them feel good you're not
going to make me feel yeah yeah yeah buy
them feeling bad yeah yeah
yeah you know many times i've gone out
to dinner with tom's a girl or i've gone
like thanks
well at that point it's not it'd be
stupid you're taking
yeah absolutely it's uh
there's more of a risk or reward factor
when you hand it off because i'm still
not confident it's coming back with a
green light no i'm still i i i have i i
haven't confidently ever swiped my debit
card ever oh i still get ptsd moments
i feel like i'm uh will in the upside
down sometimes when i'm going to swipe
because then so never have it go card do
you ever have it where it doesn't work
and you're like what do you mean and
then level center like just try it again
you're like oh okay thank god it worked
i just got denied it with my old card
yesterday oh because the order because
you didn't know it was your old one yeah
and i'm like nah run it again [ __ ]
nothing nothing nothing look at the
numbers you're like oh [ __ ] panic yeah
but that's the thing i've had it where
it's like the reader was just bad or
something yeah and you go into i just
there's three thousand dollars in that
from me i yeah i just transferred money
sure take it easy the internet's slow
relax
yeah always i always have something
locked and loaded for sure there's
something silly about three grown man
well it's cause we're talking about
pulled it back real quick i'm like all
right yeah we're doing it
we're talking about dropping checks well
we were talking about our debit cards
getting declined
hey you're a dirt bull you're a dirt
bull yeah
cheers
to scumbags because like also right when
they put the hold on your credit card at
the hotel
they're all different you know they just
[ __ ] scam but you still you use you
you don't have a credit card i don't
know i'm just getting a credit card
sooner for michael with the card they
put it back right away that's great they
release it that like that but that
doesn't even mean anything to me like
you know what i mean like if it's a
credit card that's what that's for but
i'm saying like the debit card using
that's their money that's my money you
know what i mean they're like yeah we'll
put it back next business
yeah the next business day that's
lightning quick they take a [ __ ] week
no it's [ __ ] ridiculous what they do
why am i a hundred dollars what's that
gonna do there's nothing in the [ __ ]
mini bar and there's nothing if i trash
the room what are you gonna have a
hundred bucks it's like for the ironing
board if you break it
how about we just [ __ ] chill out see
if everything's [ __ ] cool when i
leave you can check the room out if not
i'm good
okay
yes everybody walks away slowly
i had to go through a real quagmire of
like moving funds around just to check
into various hotels over the years it's
been like a bunch of shell corporations
yeah i'm just moving things around just
to check in get the holds off get them
back on singapore
i need 250. i gotta check in i want to
put just the gatorade on this one
the pretzels on this one oh that's have
you ever lied about what room you were
in i've never lied i don't i i don't
have the heart to do that and i don't
have the balls to ever put it on the
room because i always think in my trash
brain it's somehow going to be more
expensive well i'll tell you get it out
of my account i'll give it to you right
now i got the seven bucks take it now
and i want my 200 back tomorrow i'll
tell you this i have a guilty conscious
also so but i had a friend who was like
you should just say any room number and
i was like that doesn't work they check
and see who's staying there and he's
like they have a picture of he's like
watch and then he it's like the
overnight guy and he does it and i'm
like oh god and then you know what i did
i just set it to my friend's room
i'll give you that that's a good time
hey look about the sword that mother
sword you know what i
yeah
mean
luck i don't have the balls to do that
shitty no i don't like i don't like if
it was to [ __ ] over the hotel i would do
that but i don't want to [ __ ] over some
guys
i was just i just got i didn't have 12
hot pockets in the middle of the night
that was the fat guy next to me
what's this about hot pockets i was just
talking i told it on the patreon but we
went i went on a family vacation and i
was responsible for like the charges for
my room did they say that by the way was
that said to you up front
just so you know
you're
no it was understood
why is that
i don't know but i don't want to talk
about it publicly
[Laughter]
you can get to a full scoop on patreon
i would have played dumb on that one uh
well it was actually being invited out
to dinner but you got to pay for the
appetizer what are you doing here
for family for god's sake um so i picked
up a dinner there was like 14 of us like
my whole family niece's nephew's the
whole nine yards right so i picked up a
dinner
and you know there was there was a issue
with this was like two weeks ago but
there was there was an issue with
i had paid my credit card before i got
there for this reason so i'm like i got
time to i got room to dance around and
pick up a dinner and feel not like a bum
that i have for the past 35 years
and uh
i then get a call the night before i was
supposed to check out from the front
desk and i answered like a [ __ ] i'm
like yeah what do you want and they're
like your card's been declined you have
to come down oh
[ __ ]
that is the [ __ ]
word i like yeah i'm very favorite
crying in the lobby it was a very nice
hotel very embarrassing grandma's
looking kevin bozo
a holiday inn because uncle kevin
locked off it was it was not uh they
look at the worst and i in my head oh my
god probably happens all the time you
know there's probably ten guys today
that it happens oh sure and i got down
there and i'm like kevin they're like
your car got declined right like they
knew exactly
i'm surprised that the hotel didn't let
you put down cash it's usually a crazy
amount it's usually like 400 bucks yeah
it would have been a bit and i wonder if
it's because this hotel is a nice hotel
or whatever that they the the cash
staying in a nice part of town too yeah
and it's for a long stay so it's like
five nights you know what i mean i think
you want to put up on them
yeah yeah
which i would have gone down the road
and gotten and been like here you go can
i sleep now
[Laughter]
christ
you know my favorite mint mobile mint
mobile mint mobile all the way what are
you doing with these big bozos out there
telling the kick rocks with the hidden
fees and the contracts and this and this
you know why they're so expensive is
because they're dipping into it they're
wetting their beaks not mitt mobile no
pass the savings right onto you tell em
baldi 15 a month let's go
what are we doing
yeah uh like i said i've said many times
before my wife has been a user for years
she came over signed her up it's
contract free they send it right to your
door easy peasy and it is really just 15
clams it's crazy it's wild uh so if
you're looking for extra savings this
year mint mobiles offers premium
wireless plans for just 15 bucks a month
uh by going online and eliminating
traditional costs of retails mobile
passes savings right to you so you
choose yeah uh you get to choose the
amount of monthly data that you want to
use and you stop paying for data that
you never use right switch mobile get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan uh for just 15 beans and
get the plan shipped directly to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mint mobile dot com
garbage call your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at minutemobile.com
garbage do it yeah they don't take cash
and they sell no they don't do it at
nice hotels i remember the last time i
had to put cash down and i remember that
was one of the lowest
i've ever do they hand the cash back to
you at the end
i can't even remember
crumble it up and throw it in your face
okay take it to the roulette table let
it ride for me we'll mail you a check
dirt ball you don't need this right now
you're like what the [ __ ] oh it would
have been ruined it was in atlantic city
i think we were going down there to do
it no you didn't put up cash i paid for
you but wasn't i in the process of
putting in the cash you were gonna it
wasn't because i thought it was crazy
more you got real [ __ ] squirrely at
the check-in
like real [ __ ] squirrely i think it
was 200 ahead like you had to do two i
had to do two because we had two
sections
and you
were you i don't think you had it on
your card it was going to be like no
hippie can you i'll give you some cash i
can venmo you 20.
which it's like listen when you you when
you got poor comedians yes coming to do
your show
for less than two hundred dollars i
don't have the two hundred dollars to
for the oh it's a free room is it though
yeah yeah and why can't that go on the
[ __ ]
on the card that's paying for the room
we're not motley crew so yeah i'm not
going to be throwing tvs out there you
know pay your own incidentals we don't
want you charging a [ __ ] bottle of
water on there yeah
but this is how this is how poor we used
it we were i was just listening to
something else we used to be very
whatever you had we split everything
it was very like
like are we used to pool our money for
funds
so i paid for your debt facebook and
[Laughter]
we were so poor i paid your 200 but i
the deal was when we get paid
i'm taking the 200 back from you yeah oh
because it was for items i didn't i
needed it for that
of course so i'm like i'm taking 200
from you tomorrow night or whatever then
i had to wait until you had to wait
until it cleared back into my account
and then i sent you the money oh my god
if i didn't wake up every morning at 901
with a call from foley that hit yet
i called you like customer service
hi kevin it's henry sorry to bother you
again i just wanted to circle back on
that too i can't tell you how many times
i've called the hotels when i'm back
home and gone like i'm looking at my
account do you think it'll you think you
can release that early
i was really there for like eight hours
i don't know yeah
they're holding it back like they have a
button right there yeah like the woman
can just go oh we'll we'll move that
forward for you right ahead but it's
such [ __ ] man if you could take it
in a split second why the [ __ ] can't you
well
their argument is they go we release it
right away
there how many times does that happen
where it's like this red bull cost me
sixty eight dollars you know like you
know i remember i was on the phone with
td bank and i had just something hit my
account and overdrafted me and i thought
i was in a different spot and you know
like you can look and you have those i
thought there was two million in there
what the [ __ ]
this is news to me she goes so i'm
sitting there looking and the pending
charges are in a different color like
because they're pending yeah and i'm
going
that's going to be there it was like
after a weekend and there was a hundred
charges i'm like that's gonna cost me
yes that's gonna cost me thirty five
hundred dollars yeah overdraft so i
called she's like yeah it's gonna be a
lot it's criminal and i'm like i don't
have i'm like well then close the
account i'm like just [ __ ] close at
least i'll take my business elsewhere
and then i remember she had the balls
she was like she waved all of them but
like five or something i'm like all
right great
she asked me do you want to open a
savings account i'm like lady i don't
have any money without all of my money
the negative you're going to throw some
of that red in there can i just do it
let me let me throw a negative 500
please yeah what's the roth ira
situation i have so many times tried to
just either not flirt with but like just
sort of like speak sweetly to the woman
on the phone to get overdraft fees yeah
really they can always wait td bank will
wait two every six months i was an
artist i'd be like you put on some barry
white in the background not even not
like that but i would just i would like
pull the heartstrings you know what i
mean i'm like you know i used this card
for emergencies and i had
i had a big emergency last night at
p.j.o flashlights
yeah she's like you use it for is all of
your emergencies
uh [ __ ] chipotle like what is uh i
was feeding poor kids
but i would i just i've gotten so many
overdraftees reversed by just being nice
to the woman or man on the phone and i'm
just going like all right i can
well td the the person you're talking to
can wave to every six months then that
next person above them can wave another
one or two up upon their discretion yes
and remember that out there going to the
higher up
yeah that is i know that's yeah they can
do it every six months and if you have
it if they've already done it and you
call that first level again and they say
well you've had two remove in six months
you just say
i'm just i'm so can i please speak with
your with your boss real quick about it
just because
i feel like i might be able to justify
getting another one and she'll they'll
send you to the next one that guy's just
like whatever and he'll do like three
yeah no [ __ ] he's putting in his [ __ ]
sports bet for the [ __ ] yeah that guy
gets his balls broke
that's a [ __ ] horrible i mean you
asked for the supervisor for i listen if
you go in nasty you're not getting
nothing you'll get the moral victory
[ __ ] you [ __ ] this [ __ ] that
nothing i don't find any victory in that
i like i just feel worse yeah afterwards
and then also if you're polite and
they're rude to you you kind of have
this long game win
knowing that they tape that and
hopefully they use that someday
for a bad example and fire that woman
this guy's in it for the long haul yeah
i ran my mouth with like a third party
for a hotel in miami and it wasn't their
fault
and like after like all this time
i'm [ __ ] i got the manager the
[ __ ] part and i'm chewing it this is
right and i'm not like that but when you
you turn into that character yes you are
a little bit
i mean yeah we keep it all nice and
hunky dory but no but i'm saying like i
have to visit my sister she's in the
hospital i mean i'm spinning i guess
that is all checks out fair enough
you're an insane liar
i apologize it'll make sense
the only time i've ever gotten that way
was just recently when i was in the
emergency room for like 16 hours oh i
saw you two i i messaged you yeah yeah
yeah by the end of it oh yeah i was
ready to why were you in there i had a
uh abscess like on my face like grow
it's still like you could see like a
little something here that's like small
that's such a pottery thing had an
abscess on my face yeah i don't know
grown hair or something it was yeah
that's what they say they're like
sometimes an ingrown hair creates uh so
you gotta change your pillowcases that
should maybe i don't know is that what
makes an ingredient yeah
uh
but yeah that's uh that could be it um
so that's what they said ingrown hair
perhaps
and i was there for 16 hours though and
this thing kept getting like bigger as
it was going and i was starting to like
be in a lot of pain and after being in
an er for that long
i was getting cagey
and i i told the guy i go
oh that's no cigs for 16 hours well no i
was going outside but you realize we're
going outside smoking cigarettes here's
the thing the er is so
yeah a lot with your butt out
what are they handy a little buzzer like
in tgi fridays he's got the iv machine
get this we'll let you know when the
doctor is ready kazakh
and because of overcrowding the waiting
room for the er is outside
we were sitting in the ambulance bay oh
wow god and so
uh then you go like the next step is
like they bring you inside they put the
bracelet around you but you know you're
not getting called so like i was just
stepping out and smoking cigs i was so
annoyed by the end of it i was smoking
cigs like in the ambulance bay just
being like yeah i didn't usually have to
go to the street or whatever i was like
nope and they didn't head out the door
yeah i was like literally like i'm not
missing my [ __ ] name so then by the
end of it though i said to the security
guard i go
i go you're i know you have nothing to
do with this you're just keeping people
uh you know calm here whatever or like
throwing people out or psychos but i'm
gonna tell you this crazy if i don't
if they don't call me soon i'm gonna go
in the parking lot and cut it out myself
and then when i'm bleeding out there by
the ambulances that's when they'll give
me a bed and he was like chill out man
i'll get you in there i just said it
really calm to him though like i felt
like i was getting forgotten like it was
like you weren't that was like during
the one of one of the biggest waves of
the pandemic it wasn't here's the thing
the er at this you have hobo jaw
that's what it was
riding trains yeah they're dealing with
[ __ ] people with strokes and heart
attacks and probably a flooded i see all
i saw was a bunch of hobos coming in
there taking up beds and
probably not gonna when they asked me
for like address so they can send the
medical bill i'm like what's his address
where are you sending to him yeah i
don't think he's getting you have health
insurance i i have it's just started
tomorrow is tomorrow the first yeah mine
too yes yeah no i didn't what you were
off the grid for a minute i don't want
to talk about it publicly i was off the
grid for like
eight years yeah you just got it oh yeah
i jumped yeah i just got listen i'm hey
dirk bike number one right isn't it
annoying though that you can't just go
to the store and buy like
health insurance do you know what i mean
like you have to do this whole thing
where it's like open enrollment sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah what a [ __ ]
horseshit scam
i'm gonna get rid of it too as soon as i
clean myself up a little bit i'm gonna
go all right now we can live without
should you get all the abscesses out
yeah exactly cut them all out of me
brain a couple more things i think about
that too i'm i'm in the big run of
appointments and stuff like that and you
know you think once you get a clean bill
you get out because it's crazy yeah a
lot of money
it's
bananas yeah this country is something
else
usa
take that commie ship back to the coast
well yeah
meanwhile he's threatened security
guards yeah at the e.r
uh i didn't threaten him that actually
guy was a he listened to my show and i
just told him i'm like here's the deal
he knew me from my show and i go here's
the deal this is what i'm i'm losing my
mind man talking about not meeting your
heroes yeah right
hey i used to listen to potter until i
saw him in a parking lot trying to stab
himself yeah fan of the show i'm gonna
slit my throat
you performing anywhere local coming up
listen here i'll get you out yeah
exactly i'm gonna steal your gun okay
you're gonna be at the store later
tonight i'm gonna cut my throat open
with a cold razor steal that ambulance
drive it through the front of the
hospital i'm like the joker
[Laughter]
so what'd they do they drained it oh
yeah did they give you an antibiotic for
it oh tons
the whole i got two actually and i uh
they gave me some norcos as well norcos
oh yeah what's norco's that's just your
run-of-the-mill pain opiate opioid
norcos i've never heard of that is that
a norco's term no it's uh um i work i
used to work for a doctor doing like
transcribing which i was terrible at i
was like falling asleep when i would
type it and [ __ ] like i was bad like a
court reporter yeah yeah it's like
doctors have that a doctor talks into a
thing and then you type it up for his
probably 20.
10 bucks if you got it 20 bucks by the
ambulance bay
it's so funny though i had to go back in
two days later to the er again for the
follow-up didn't take away sorry about
yesterday
things got a little out of hand
back in the second time well this was so
it was like i'm sitting there and uh i
go by the way uh
those norcos they're gone i mean they i
ran out they dropped them they fell in a
sewer i apologize yeah they were like
well we can only give you that many for
like 40 days or something like that so
they
she's like i can't give you any more and
i'm like
all right
i didn't i didn't really need them i
just want [ __ ] she knew that yeah yeah
yeah i got a big weekend coming up
i got a bachelor party for my buddy
steve this was all very traumatic
good with a couple of those guys
i told the guys i was passionate one of
the girls not only fans
told her i was knocked up i thought i
could give her one
all right uh let's see this one's from
rory do you currently only have one
light bulb in a multiple light bulb
fixture
example one light bulb and a ceiling fan
that takes three that's got to be your
whole apartment well i have
i'll say this i have electricity i have
a ceiling fan that has like four and
only two of them are in operation are
the other two still in there though the
old bulbs yeah there's okay i moved in
that's a little better i feel like i
moved in and they were like that and i
just never replaced them what's the dust
situation on that ceiling fan you know
what's so funny
as a blind man
i had no i i just didn't even think
about the dust on the ceiling fan and
then i looked at it
and it was like there were
uh feathers coming off the side like i
went up
from it i went up on a step stool i go
oh my lord the ceiling fan has
but you know what it is i run it
i like his old lady response oh my lord
there's a chicken in my apartment i
usually run it constantly though so it's
usually was always just like even when i
was gone it was just like er someday
it'll just fly off there i'm sure but
then i you know once it sits there for a
while it gets like tails it's crazy
the ceiling fan when it's done right
it's pretty classy but when you get into
a situation like that like i bet your
light fixture shakes yeah it spins
around well because of the wooden things
the person that lives above it so like
they stomp around so like every time
they do my things like
like rattles the ceiling fan i'm waiting
for this thing to fly off and kill me
someday there's one in my mom's house
that hasn't that just doesn't shut off
for whatever reason wow
the switch on the wall doesn't matter
it's just been cooking for like 14 years
it's like wow
just waiting for it to go down someday
yeah something's going to happen at some
point absolutely a lot of [ __ ] well
nowadays when you have those
just the ceiling lights that have two
sockets if you throw one of those
[ __ ]
halogen lamps or whatever in there you
don't need two no no that's a nice mood
too when you were a kid uh did you ever
throw things into the ceiling fan oh
yeah yeah that was my favorite [ __ ]
mosquitoes and [ __ ] yeah i lost well i
just threw like pillows and [ __ ] i
didn't throw like animals or anything
what do you mean oh the ceiling fan yeah
yeah oh yeah while it's like cranking
you just [ __ ] throw [ __ ] up and break
it it was really cool when it would go
up hit the ceiling and come down and
you're like what just happened oh yeah
we'll go through it yeah yeah that was
fun games yeah that's a real like when
you're just a kid playing with the
ceiling fan yeah that's the trash
breaking [ __ ] just literally just
breaking [ __ ] yeah
breaking [ __ ] was fun yeah it was the
best we talked about it before but i
think the
those long like tube lamps oh they're
like lightsabers yeah [ __ ] hitting
each other with those things yeah it's a
good [ __ ] time
dude everything's so dangerous every
dirt everything is it you gotta wear
goggles bulbs oh i never wore them
goggles we were behind we're at the
loading dock of a shop well i would my
yeah we weren't in double there what are
you talking about
in green jumpsuits
those things are full of like phosphorus
or some [ __ ] yeah it's bad news the
wrestlers hit each other here
because that's who you're talking about
right i guess
or four high kids behind a supermarket
you know it became real trashy is that
one
stand uh
light
that had the little dimmer on it it was
black remember and it shined up oh yeah
it was like yeah every slime ball had
that in their apartment [ __ ] in the
air oh trying to get laid you know what
i'm talking about i had the dimmer on it
it was like gold trim on it a little bit
or like the knob standing
i had one of those that was my only i
had that a television and an air
mattress in my cleveland apartment for
the entirety that i lived there that was
but it was only richest man in cleveland
it was only a year but i didn't uh i
looked like a psycho and then it was it
would come apart when you move [ __ ]
nuts so you like take you screw off the
top and then you can screw the middle up
like a sniper
[Laughter]
all right let's do a couple more here um
this one's just funny this is from tim
uh any of your social media friends
actively posting online within a prison
because that's a really big thing now
they all have they all have cell phones
and access somehow i think i mean
dancing in jail on tick-tock is huge
yeah prison or tick-tock is like a real
thing some of them are like gourmet
chefs you know how they do like food
like chi-chi and [ __ ] yeah they're doing
like this how i make tacos and they're
like doing all this [ __ ] in the toilet
it's crazy how many people are
how many grown men are in prison so
they're criminals and they're just like
doing doing like dance trends it's wild
the only person and i don't even know
him well but i rode the school bus with
him i rode the school bus with a guy who
got arrested at the insurrection
uh or because of the insurrection i
should say and uh he's made a tomato
he's like he's like also he makes these
headlines
this kid from my hometown that i rode
the school bus with
when you were a kid right yeah yeah i
want to make that clear no yeah he may
and so he makes uh all these headlines
he just made the headlines because he's
trying to get like he's banned from the
internet forever like he can't have a
facebook account he can't because he's
susceptible to like
who made the ban like fate or the
governor of the government yeah because
he was a insurrectionist at the capitol
oh geez so they're like you're not
allowed to use twitter you're not
allowed to use you can't read news stuff
like that i can't read news it's like
it's a really wild sentence but he's
trying to get a portion of it appealed
so he could just have tinder
and like [ __ ] women on tinder
hey judge i'm trying to get my wiener
wet over here it like was a big headline
they're like an insurrectionist is
trying to
amend his sentencing as he's trying to
meet women on the internet
why they gotta have tinder some version
of that for the insurrectionists
i mean they're not this this guy's
is he's not allowed to like use the
internet any apps or anything is that a
real thing can they do that i govern
federal government and start throwing
her weight around yikes yeah then you
end up in internet cafes and stuff like
i don't that's the thing that's like
next thing you got a predator [ __ ]
drone flying already yeah right you know
what i mean minority report
checking your little spiders are looking
in your eyes
[Laughter]
just trying to get a tinder account man
um all right this one's a home run have
you this is from tj have you ever
planned the days you go on vacation so
your paycheck would hit halfway through
it
every [ __ ] vacation i never even
risked taking a vacation but i used to
we were i was just talking about this
with my buddy matt wayne who used to do
open mics with me back in buffalo i used
to get paid by like uh bi-weekly or
whatever so
every tuesday we'd go do this show
and
every time you'd see me i'd go this is a
power tuesday yeah we call it power
tuesdays because i just got paid and i
didn't have to pay my rent on that one
so i'd be like we got the goods yeah
yeah exactly now we can rage yeah that
buy that the bi-weekly non-rent payment
yeah
and every time you're like i'm going to
save half of this
that's the good times right there oh
sometimes you get out of pocket and you
do that overdraft and then the rent
comes and you're like
well we're going to be short
start [ __ ] get a sticky wicket there
let me ask you this i'm listening it's
probably going back a few years so
you'll have to think a little bit
do you remember the last time
that the norm was cashing your check
uh yeah i used to not even i had a bank
account with
m t
that they were coming after me for
overdraft fees for me and so i couldn't
open another one and i just didn't i
would i thought that i couldn't open a
bank account anywhere but like he was
talking to chase yes
like the pinkertons and so i would do i
would go to uh one of those check
cashing places
and pay a dollar to get it instantly oh
yeah
my last
i worked up until
last march i think so like yeah
not even a full year ago i would go
there would be time i would half the
time i would deposit half the times i
would go to because it was written on a
chase account or a citibank i would go
to a citibank sometimes they give you
[ __ ] with that a lot of times they do
with this sleazeball episode
i see the ins and outs of how to be a
how to survive as a director oh my god i
mean there was like four years where i
just didn't have a bank account yeah i
didn't have because i was scared that
they were gonna like they all knew
that i couldn't open a bank account with
m t yeah me too i figured on the streets
potter's over there at chase
yeah like oh him don't let him uh come
in by the tellers are calling each other
potter's floating checks about five
seven five eight classes yeah that's him
that's the son of a [ __ ] right there
mentioned something about power tuesday
he has to talk to my supervisor for no
reason
yeah no [ __ ]
the cashing of the check big i mean very
[ __ ] big yeah of course well
sometimes i would have to get that rent
due on time i couldn't deposit it
because that was you know if it was a
friday that was a business day or two
they hold it they're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] so i would go to citibank it's
20 21. lightning quick we should be
doing that you can put half of it in but
no yeah we'll clear 200 hey but it's
only 205. let's go oh yeah [ __ ] and i
need that five yeah they're clear
i'll be dead by then what do you mean
clear 200. i'll never forget this i was
at the this is like not that long ago a
couple years ago i was in la
and they have all these clubs outside of
la like the ontario improv irvine improv
so i was at one of these
levity live maybe in oxnard
and i knew i was going to get a check
and i'd have to uber home because i
couldn't take the train home because the
train shuts down so the uber home is
going to be a little pricey and i get my
i know i'm going to get a check at the
club
so i needed to deposit the check so that
the uber would go
without overdraft so at my bank you can
deposit a check and the funds go in
instantly no matter what time but i
didn't realize that's because that's my
like home bank
so i'm at a chase bank that i walked
like two or three miles to from the club
deposit the check it goes it'll be
available on monday and i go
so i'm still over drafting this super
after all that
i'm still overdrafting the super he's
like i'm staying in
till monday
now what i learned with uber though is
if you when you do uber off the hours
that charge doesn't go like you can do
it through paypal paypal will kick it
till monday yes yes yeah well uber
sometimes you can get away with that too
lift is real stingy lift [ __ ] takes
it out they do a pre-approved yeah yeah
like hey we're gonna hold 32 bucks if
you canceled a ride it's
what do you do it's very much like the
hotel yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
but paper i learned putting things on
paypal
pushes them to the business days just so
now you're the you're twisting it on
them yeah you got a couple days to get
your affairs in order you know what i
mean
i remember i didn't use uber for a long
time because i had it outstanding and
every time i would go to it they'd be
like
really yeah there's outstanding ubers oh
yeah if you don't if you don't close out
the last one they don't let you use a
new one
i'm banned from lyft
writing bad checks what happened with
there has something happened with you
very recently where i was talking i'm on
the phone with venmo i'm like that's the
worst sentence ever you should never be
on the phone with venmo i think i told
you about my venmo thing last time where
i was
committing credit card fraud against oh
you did yeah yeah hey i had a phone call
they called me venmo called me
credit card fraud against my i really
screwed that son of a [ __ ]
take that josh potter inc
exactly
gang mr josh potter the host of the josh
potter show buddy what do you got coming
up you want the folks to know oh boy
well i got a patreon out there just like
you folks and uh check it out get on it
five bucks to start that's it that's all
for now once we get cooking and get some
more things up there maybe we'll change
the tiers and things like that but come
on over it's uh been pumping out content
like crazy and of course the josh potter
shows every tuesday look for it on
youtube the channel's just the josh
potter show it's easy to find and as far
as gigs go i'll be in uh
irvine improv on the 11th i'll be in san
diego on the 23rd so just uh go to my
socials and check that all out yes sir
buddy one of the best one of the
funniest we love you thank you so much
so uh awesome to be in the studio too
for this first time
[ __ ] zoom and then uh
and the first time here so that's great
love it we appreciate it buddy kippy
what do you got for him uh kevin ryan on
all social media come to a [ __ ] show
we're all over the [ __ ] road check
out the patreon the whole nine yards
youtube oh also the clips channel we
just launched the clips channel check
that out uh it'll be in the details gang
we love you t-bone we'll see you next
week peace